this is one of the biggest stories this
week and it is fascinating Donald
Trump's former Secretary of Defense Jim
mattis has completely denounced and
condemned Donald Trump and predictably
Donald Trump went completely off the
deep end exploding in an unhinged tirade
last night it's truly something and I'm
not aware of any time in history that a
Secretary of Defense has denounced the
president they served so brutally and
soak so completely and so so
wholeheartedly I asked for other
examples yesterday on Twitter
was not given any now I want to be clear
I'm not any particular fan of Jim mattis
I'm not you know I wasn't a big fan of
Trump's former Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson but it can't be denied that
they were two of the calmer voices in
Trump's administration who were even
remotely connected to reality now since
leaving his position as Secretary of
Defense Jim mattis hasn't said very much
about Donald Trump and he even said I
think it was about a year ago or so
roughly that he doesn't really plan or
think it's appropriate I'm summarizing
here to criticize the sitting president
the president they work for clearly that
has changed and Jim mattis has now
denounced Trump and accused him of
ordering the military to violate the
constitutional rights of Americans
understand that the former Trump's own
former Secretary of Defense is accusing
Trump of trying to violate the
constitutional rights of Americans let's
look at some of mattis's letter then we
will get trump's explosive and
completely predictable reaction mattis
wrote I have watched this week's
unfolding events angry and appalled the
words equal justice under law are carved
in the pediment of the United States
Supreme Court this is precisely
precisely what protesters are rightly
demanding it is a wholesome and unifying
demand one that all of us should be able
to get behind
we must not be distracted by a small
number of lawbreakers the protests are
defined by tens of thousands of people
of conscience who are insisting that we
live up to our values our values as
people and our values as a nation we
must reject and hold accountable those
in office who would make a mockery of
our Constitution then Jim mattis goes on
to say in this letter
absolutely brutally that quote Donald
Trump is the first president in my
lifetime who does not try to unite the
American people does not even pretend to
try instead he tries to divide us we are
witnessing the consequences of three
years of this deliberate effort we are
witnessing the consequences of three
years without mature leadership we can
unite without him drawing on the
strength and tarrant in our civil
society this will not be easy as the
past few days have shown but we owe it
to our fellow citizens to pass
generations that bled to defend our
promise and to our children then madis
who if nothing else he chooses his words
carefully actually references Nazis
saying quote instructions given by the
military departments to our troops
before the Normandy invasion reminded
soldiers that the Nazi slogan for
destroying us was divide and conquer our
American answer is in Union there is
strength we must summon that unity to
surmount this crisis confident that we
are better than our politics and then
lastly talking about the Constitution
which like him or not
and I'm no big mattis fan he genuinely
does seem to care about the Constitution
regardless of who it is that is in power
saying quote when I joined the military
some fifty years ago I swore an oath to
support and defend the Constitution
never did I dream that troops taking
that same oath would be ordered under
any circumstance to violate the
constitutional rights of their fellow
citizens much less to provide a bizarre
photo-op for the elected
commander-in-chief with military
leadership standing alongside
referencing of course that horrifying
photo op earlier this week where Donald
Trump gassed protests had protesters
gassed he didn't do it himself to clear
a path to his Bible photo op in front of
st. John's Church I am not aware of such
a brutal takedown of a president by
their own former Secretary of Defense if
you have an example I am more than
to see it now Trump's reaction you have
to see Trump's reaction when the maddest
letter was published yesterday I was
just waiting for Trump to go completely
crazy it took a couple of hours but he
eventually did tweeting quote probably
the only thing Barack Obama and I have
in common is that we both had the honor
of firing Jim mattis the world's most
overrated general I asked for his letter
of resignation and felt great about it
his nickname was chaos which I didn't
like and changed to Mad Dog
his primary strength was not military
but rather personal public public
relations I gave him a new life things
to do in battles to win but he seldom
brought home the bacon I didn't like his
leadership style or much else about him
and many others agree glad he is gone
now what's really amazing about Trump's
response is that you know Trump's
furious you can see his anger Trump is
seething that his own former Secretary
of Defense brutally has condemned him
but he can't really come up with much to
criticize Jim mattis with he's an
overrated general that Trump said that
so many times it's a milquetoast insult
I didn't like his nickname so I changed
it who cares
he was better at PR than military stuff
that speaks more about Trump's poor
judgment of who to hire right Trump ran
on I will hire the best people how if
this is true if Matt mattis is better at
PR than military stuff how did Trump
stupidly hire them to run the Secretary
of Defense you don't have to like mattis
I am no Big Jim mattis fan but if you
say whose values do I prefer guiding the
country Trump's which are me me me or
mattis's which at least are ostensibly
the Constitution and an appropriate
interpretation of it I pick mattis over
Trump every time now one more thing
mattis seems to have the goods on Trump
by all estimates if Jim mattis wanted to
he could actually reveal things about
Trump that maybe worse than anything
we've seen yesterday when the maddest
letter came out New York Times magazines
Robert Draper tweeted
quote madis is still holding back though
he's privately told friends that Trump's
behavior is far worse than the reports
and that the Republic is on shaky
footing he knows so much more than he's
currently divulging the reporting is a
horror a horror story so if the truth is
worse than the reporting as Jim mattis
reportedly said imagine what we don't
know imagine what we might know in four
weeks as Donald Trump continues to
unravel part of that unraveling appears
to be Trump's campaign looking at the
20/20 map and panicking and that's what
I want to talk about next
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka stinkiest has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video